my first job was a teacher a substitute
teacher it's my first day in school and
this one kid comes in and he sees me and
he's like I need to think of ways to
make my own revenge and when you walk
into high school and you see a TV you're
like yeah watching a movie
what so I bring the TV in and the kids
walk in but I guess watch and then I
would take attendance and then I would
stand up and be like oh what's this
doing here from the last class and I
push it out like take out your textbooks
and then what happened was the kids
wised up to it the next step was I was
going to set it up do what Tennant and
have the kids all be like oh he's not
even gonna do it but then I would press
play on the TV
I was like oh [ __ ] we are watching movie
turn off the lights and the movie would
start and it would be a recording of me
being like open up your textbooks and
then I would conduct the entire lesson
from the TV while I sat down and did my
you know my correcting or whatever it is
isn't it amazing that I'm no longer a
teacher
the first epic Meal Time episode came
out while I was still teaching and I
went to substitute teach the next week
and I came in they're all like yo sir we
saw your crazy burger video man who saw
you drinking beer on your videos it's so
crazy and I realized at that point you
know I'm gonna be releasing these videos
all the time the kids will never take me
seriously if I'm drinking Jack Daniels
and wrapping things in bacon on the
internet every week so I made a decision
I was like you know what at the end of
the day kids bounce now I have a TV show
Epic Meal Empire thank you for watching
make sure you subscribe to GQ for more
videos like this and leave a comment in
the comment section below about your
first job and then someone trained is
going to read all of those comments and
assess what the demographic of this
channel is and further capitalise on the
content in the future